in the episode of doctor who i ask you
to watch for this lecture
one called parallels season seven
episode 11.
what no i asked him to watch blink
parallels is that episode of next
generation where
all those versions of lieutenant wharf
warbs the plural of wharf is warbs
sorry about that i have no idea where
that video came from
anyway what i asked you to watch was
blink
a doctor who episode from 2007.
in it sally sparrow discovers an alien
race
called the weeping angels the angels
freeze into stone
when they're being observed but can kill
you
when they're not by sending you back in
time
and feeding off the potential energy of
the future days you would have lived
essentially letting you live to death
this is how they've trapped the doctor a
time lord
in 1969 without his time machine
the tardis which is stuck in 2007.
to get it back he arranges for billy
shipton
to plant easter eggs secret video clips
on 17 different dvds
the 17 that sally sparrow owns
these easter eggs show the doctor
carrying on
half a conversation where's the other
half
in 2007 carried on by sally sparrow
the doctor's able to maintain his half
of the conversation
because he has a transcript of what she
will say
38 years before she'll say it
how well when sally finally watches the
easter egg
she figures out that the doctor is
talking to her
and carries on her half of the
conversation
sally's friend larry then writes it
down then at the end of the episode
after sally sends the tardis back to the
doctor in 1969
she runs into the doctor at a moment in
his life
before he is trapped in 1969.
she gives him the transcript so that one
day in his future when he needs it to
create the easter eggs
he will have it the question to consider
is this
does sally give the doctor this
transcript because she was saved by the
doctor
or was she saved by the doctor because
she gave him
the transcript the doctor in sally's
conversation
seems to have no causal origin
take the doctors half of the
conversation although larry writes it
down
he is only copying what the doctor says
yet the doctor only says what he says
because it's written down
on the transcript so
who is the author of the doctor's words
it's not larry he's only copying the dvd
but it's not the doctor he's just
reading off the transcript
as we discussed last lecture a
self-created object like this
is called a ginny and jyn that's the
plural of jenny
are all over this episode of doctor who
for example at the beginning of the
episode
sally is with her friend kathy
nightingale in an abandoned house
she leaves her behind when she hears the
doorbell
ring because kathy is alone and unaware
of the danger
the angels touch her and manage to send
her
into the past once there kathy meets a
boy
has a family and eventually a grandson
and it was the grandson who rang the
doorbell
he had promised his grandmother kathy
that he would deliver a letter to
sally at this moment in time yet it was
only because sally was distracted by the
grandson and him ringing the doorbell
that the angels were able to get to
kathy
so does the grandson's visit caused
kathy to be sent into the past
or does kathy being trapped in the past
caused the grandson's
visit as we've seen
the possibility of jinn seems to make
time travel into the past
impossible after all causes always
precede their effects
right so if a caused b a
came before b but if b also
caused a then b came before a
but by the principle of transitivity
that means that b
came before itself and that's logically
impossible
so time travel into the past is
logically
impossible this argument however
against time travel to the past begs the
question
time travel essentially is the
suggestion that causes sometimes
come after their effects if marty
travels from 1985 to 1955
his activation of his time machine in
1985
comes after but is the cause of him
appearing in 1955. so if your argument
against the possibility of time travel
begins by assuming that it's impossible
for effects to precede their causes
you're basically just assuming the truth
of what you're trying to prove
so that argument won't work
the problem with gin actually goes
deeper
regardless of what temporal direction
the causal arrow points
it seems that causal explanations have
to bottom
out somewhere unless you arrive at a
stopping point
you really haven't explained anything
but with gin there is no stopping point
a cause b which caused a which caused b
and on and on and on and on this it
seems
leaves jin without an explanation for
their existence they have
no causal origin and if there is no
explanation for why they exist
then logically they can't exist right
since time travel into the past would
entail that they could exist
time travel into the past must be
impossible
that's the argument
but that argument makes us wonder are
gin
really logically impossible is there is
there really something incoherent
about the concept itself
not really to explain why let me
slightly modify some of the doctor's
words
people assume that time is a strict
progression of moments
the past the present the future but
actually
from a non-linear non-subjective
viewpoint it's more like a block
of wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey
stuff that sentence kind of got away
from me
but what does it mean well
our experience tells us that there is a
fact
about what moments are past present and
future
at any given well at any given
moment in the beginning the big bang was
the present moment and
everything else was future later the jfk
assassination
was in the present moment and everything
else was either
past or future at another point the sun
exploding will be a present moment etc
and if two events are simultaneous
that's because they happened they were
both
present at the same time
but einstein's relativity teaches us
that this is not
correct why because motion
and consequently simultaneity
are relative to a reference frame
now what does that mean think of two
spaceships about to collide say the
millennium falcon
and the starship enterprise from the
falcons perspective
or frame of reference it's stationary
and the enterprise is moving towards it
but from the enterprises perspective
it's it's stationary and it's the falcon
that's moving
and from the perspective of someone say
on
battlestar galactica watching this whole
thing the falcon
and the starship enterprise are moving
towards each other
what relativity teaches us is that no
one of these perspectives
is more correct than another these are
all equally accurate ways of describing
what's happening just like you might say
that
your fork is to the right of your plate
and someone across the table
might say it's to the left and you'd
both be right
according to relativity there is no fact
of the matter about what's really moving
and what's
really stationary it's all
relative what follows from this
once you realize that the speed of light
is the same in all reference frames
is that there is also no fact of the
matter regarding whether events
are simultaneous if they are
simultaneous in one frame
they won't be in another and neither
description is
right or fully captures what really
happened the classic thought experiment
used to explain this involves two people
one inside a moving train and one
outside it
and lights that turn on one on the
front of the train and then one on the
back of the train
whose light beams meet in the middle of
the train
from the perspective of the person
inside the train
the lights turned on at the same time
middle
but from the other person's perspective
the backlight turned on
first since the train is moving towards
the front light and away from
the backlight that's the only way that
their light beams would be able to meet
in the middle of the train and the speed
of light
not change now i know that was quick
i go into it in much more detail in
exploring metaphysics but the upshot is
this
because simultaneity is relative
for any given event a and any other
event
b that happens after it there will
always be some other event
c such that c is simultaneous with a
in one reference frame but also
simultaneous with b
in another but the only way that can be
the case
is if all these events exist together
and that's why relativity contradicts
the common progressive
view of time because the only way
that can all be true is if all moments
what we would call
past present and future exist
as a whole in a giant block a block
that has a bunch of different reference
frames running through it
all dictating different things about
which events are simultaneous with
others in different frames
but none capturing the full truth
kind of like a big block
of wibbly wobbly timey wyami stuff
indeed there is not even a fact of the
matter
about what moment in time is
the present moment and which moments are
passed and which ones are future
they all just exist the jfk
assassination
is happening just as much as my
utterance of these words
is happening they're all just moments in
time
we seem to experience them in a
progression
but as einstein once said people like us
who believe in physics know that the
distinction
between past present and future is only
a stubbornly persistent
illusion indeed in the previously
discussed movie arrival
it seems that looking beyond this
illusion is what learning the alien's
language
enables dr banks to do she can see
the entire timeline the block
as a whole she no longer sees it in the
inaccurate way
that humans do as a progression from
past
to future but realizing
that this is the true nature of time
allows us to realize that there is
nothing paradoxical at all about
chin they seem paradoxical
because they were running around in a
circle
a cause b and b caused a the causal
explanation
doesn't end anywhere they have no causal
origin
but if all of time is a giant block
which contains
all moments in time they do have a
causal origin the gin
came into existence along with
everything else
as the entire block came into existence
if we think of the universe as being
created it was not created as a batch of
matter
that grew and developed and became more
complicated over time
it did not start with a single moment
and then progress into a series of
moments
all of space and time the entire block
past present and future
came into existence as a whole all at
once
we might say with its entire history
intact
so that's the case why couldn't it have
a gin within it
the explanation for them would be the
existence
of the block itself or you could think
of it this way
when it comes to a ginny nothing is
unexplained
a explains b and b explains a and
there's nothing else to explain
now you might think that the circle
itself
needs to be explained but why think that
if you don't demand an explanation for
like the line itself in the case of
linear causation in both cases
whatever accounts for the existence of
the block
suffices to explain either the jenny or
the line
richard hanley defends the possibility
of jinn in his fascinating article
no end in sight causal loops in
philosophy physics
and fiction he identifies many different
kinds
of causal loops such as object loops and
information loops and he points out that
some loops are easier to account
for than others physical objects that
exist in a loop will require some way to
ensure that their
matter is replenished but at worst
causal loops of any kind only require a
grand coincidence they are not
logically incoherent it's even possible
to be one's own father or mother
what's more since the actions of
conscious agents can easily make
grand coincidences occur causal loops
are
much more likely in a universe like ours
one that has
conscious agents in it
[Music]
so causal loops don't negate the
possibility
of time travel to the past but what
about
the grandfather paradox the other
objection to time travel that we
considered
last lecture it illustrates how time
travel would make it possible to
annihilate yourself
before you traveled in time by say
killing your grandfather before he sires
your father
this would create a paradox where you
annihilate yourself
if and only if you don't since that is
not even
possibly true the argument goes time
travel into the past cannot possibly
occur but many philosophers agree
that this argument is not sound in fact
there are two ways
to avoid the conclusion of this argument
but before i explain them
it's important to point out that you
can't answer the argument
by avoiding the problem like the
characters
in futurama did in the futurama episode
i ask you to watch
roswell that ends well the gang travels
to the past and ends up causing
the famous 1947 roswell ufo incident
they are the ship that crashes professor
farnsworth warns fry
not to kill his own grandfather enos but
fry's efforts to prevent this end up
resulting in his grandfather's death
fry places enos a bit too near a nuclear
test site
the writers avoid the paradox however by
having fry
sleep with his own grandmother thus
making fry
his own grandfather essentially instead
of annihilating himself
fry becomes a ginny this does not
solve the grandfather paradox however it
merely avoids
invoking one why because
the argument does not suggest that every
instance of time travel
would include a self-annihilation
paradox
so telling a time-traveled story that
avoids one
doesn't answer the argument
what it does suggest what the argument
does suggest is that time travel to the
past
seems to make possible something that is
impossible
self annihilation to solve the paradox
one must explain why time travel could
never allow for the possibility of
self-annihilation
to do so you basically have to
reconceive
the very nature of what time travel
would do
and there are two ways to do this
the first is called branching
time travel a solution to the problem
endorsed by philosophers
newell belnap and david deutsch the
suggestion is this
when you travel back in time you do not
travel to your
own past you travel to the past
of an alternate universe which has a
past
just like the universe you left up to
the moment
to which you traveled but that also
contains the event of you the time
traveler
appearing at that moment you then
proceed forward in time in that universe
and deal with the consequences of your
actions there
but you can't kill your own grandfather
because your grandfather is in the past
of the universe you left you traveled to
a different universe
with a different grandfather if you kill
him
you will simply prevent that universe's
version
of you from being born but the event of
your birth
is still safe and sound in your original
universe
this conception of time travel can quite
handily be used to make perfect sense
of many time travel stories take the
first season of the nbc show
heroes for example a show about heroes
with special
powers granted by their unusual dna
it involved multiple episodes of time
travel into the past
by a time traveler named hero
if you keep careful track as morgan luck
did in his chapter of my book
heroes and philosophy you can
demonstrate that the story
is consistent every time hero jumps back
he creates a new universe
now by the end of the first season we
are in our fourth universe and
hero is the only character that is
actually from the original universe
but the story is at least logically
consistent although it does
solve the grandfather paradox branching
time travel cannot be used to make sense
of every time
travel story even ones that explicitly
try to explain
their plot with the branching view
take the second back to the future movie
doc brown and marty
travel from the peaceful town of hill
valley in 1985
to hill valley 2015. while they're there
biff steals the delorean to travel back
to 1955
and give himself a sports almanac and
then returns the time machine
to 2015. doc and marty then use it to
return to hill valley in 1985
only to find that it is now a lawless
dystopian
wasteland explains this development
by saying that biff giving his younger
self the almanac
created an alternate timeline in which
he gained wealth
that enabled him to ruin the town and
that is the timeline in which they are
now in
but that's not how branching time travel
works
if 2015 biff created an alternate
universe when he stole the delorean to
travel to 1955
then when he went back to the future he
should have arrived at the 2015
of that alternate universe one where
that universe's biff is
old and rich he should not have returned
to the future of the universe
he left where he got the delorean from
doc and marty in the first place
but that's what happens in the movie in
reality
marty and doc would have been stranded
in 2015
without a time machine and if they built
a new one and traveled back to 1985
they would have found it just like they
left it because
it would have been an alternate universe
just like the one they left
up to 1985.
to make sense of other stories you have
to tweak
the branching time travel theory a bit
take
donnie darko for example it tells the
story of a boy who was
out for a walk one night when out of
nowhere
while he's communicating with a
psychedelic rabbit
a jet plane engine lands on his bedroom
somewhat thankful to be alive he
continues to live his life
and then falls in love with a girl named
gretchen
but his meeting her ultimately although
accidentally
leads to her death when presented with
the opportunity to go
back and be in his bedroom when the
engine falls on it
he takes it and dies thus
saving her life now
i'm not doing the movie justice it's way
trippier than that but it seems to
explain itself in terms of alternate
universes
indeed the fictitious book featured in
the film the philosophy of time travel
actually speaks in terms of tangent
universes
and this it seems is what the
psychedelic rabbit
meant when he said the world was about
to
end the universe in which donny lives
will end and a new one where donnie dies
will be created but if we are to explain
the plot in terms of
branching time travel there's one little
hitch
if donnie's traveling into in time
created a
duplicate universe just like the one he
left right up to the moment before the
engine fell on his room
well that universe would also contain a
duplicate donnie
out for a walk who would go on to live
his life
to make the story work time travel
must not only create a duplicate
universe but must also
erase the duplicate of the time traveler
from that duplicate universe
at the moment of the time traveler's
arrival
now that's fun but
although branching time travel can make
sense of many time travel stories
and solve the grandfather paradox
it still has two noteworthy consequences
first it's not clear that it's really
time travel
although it would look like time travel
to the time traveler
it's really just alternate universe
creation
so to accomplish this you would need to
invent a machine capable of creating
specific kinds of alternate universes
not a machine capable of traveling in
time
this fact was demonstrated quite
hilariously
in the short film one minute time
machine
that uses a slightly different version
of branching time travel
it tells the story of a man trying to
pick up a woman
when he makes a pick up mistake he
undoes it
by traveling one minute back in time
to try again in the end however
he learns that he's not traveling in
time his
time machine actually just kills its
user
and creates a duplicate universe set one
minute in the past
where another version of the user with
memories of the original
tries to pick up a different version of
the same
woman and he does this 16
times and towards the end of the film
we're treated to a montage of the
previous universes
where each subsequent woman is freaking
out about the guy who just tried to pick
her up
hit a button on a box and then suddenly
died
as the woman puts it it's not a time
machine it's a
suicide machine it's a murder box
the second consequence of branching time
travel is the realization
that it just might not be very useful
for example you can't actually affect
changes
to your own timeline you can only create
a different timeline
that's more to your liking indeed
if you travel forward again it will just
be into the future of
the new universe you created and if you
travel back again
you'll just create yet another universe
you can never return to the universe
you left consider hero again from the
nbc show heroes
he travels into the future to see that
new york city is destroyed in an
explosion
so he goes back in time to prevent it
but the new york city he ends up saving
is in the fourth universe he created the
new york city
of the original universe is still
destroyed
[Music]
a second solution to the grandfather
paradox was developed by philosopher
david lewis
he suggests that time travel would not
give one the ability to kill their own
grandfather
because doing so would be impossible
essentially because you'd be predestined
not
to do so why well
think back to the block world view of
time
in which the entire universe past
present and future exists
as a whole if time travel is possible
the universe already contains the events
of the time
travelers traveling in time their
escapades in what
we would call both the future and the
past
that means before a time traveler ever
activates their time machine the things
that they will do
while in the past have already occurred
the past is already written so they can
travel there
and experience the past they can even
participate
causing things to happen in the past
but it would be impossible for them to
cause
anything to happen other than what they
had
already caused and since
they clearly were born and thus
preventing their own birth
is clearly not something that they
already caused
it would be impossible for them to do so
or if you're like fry it would be
impossible for you to
not become your own grandfather
it may seem to them from their own
subjective point of view
that they can do whatever they want a
time traveler might even learn that
they died in the past and travel back in
time to try to prevent it
but they can't there are facts
about what the past contains and they
would not be able to alter
those facts this view
of how time travel works what we might
call the luisian pre-destination view
was illustrated quite nicely by data
in times arrow a star trek next
generation episode
in which the crew discovers that data's
head
has been buried underneath san francisco
since the late
19th century riker suggests
that they can try to prevent this from
happening but data
observes that any such attempt would be
futile
there is no way anyone can prevent it
sir at some future date
i will be transported to the 19th
century earth or i will die
it has occurred it will occur
and he's right the crew is unable to
undo
this fact indeed their attempts to
prevent it
are what cause it to happen data travels
to the past
and then a time portal violently
detaches his head from his body
leaving his head in the 19th century but
transporting his body
back to the 24th data was simply
mistaken
that this would result in his death the
crew is able to save his life
by attaching the head they found
underneath san francisco
in the 24th century back onto his body
that landed in the 24th century
now luisian predestination doesn't make
time travelers look very free
indeed once they travel to the past
the time traveler is predefined to do
what the timeline dictates
that they have already done but the same
is true
for the rest of us in the block world
view of time
the future already exists just as much
as the past does
the actions that non-time travelers like
you and me will perform
are already written as well they are
just in the future of the block
not the past it may seem from our
subjective point of view
that we can do whatever we want but
really we can
only perform the actions the future
already contains
us performing we can't change them
any more than we could change the past
the universe exists
as a whole past present and future
indeed the only difference it seems
between the time
traveler and us is how the moments of
our lives are arranged
in a block mine are neatly arranged in
chronological order
the doctors for example are all cut up
into pieces and scattered throughout
but since it exists as a whole
neither of us can do anything other than
what
the block contains
interestingly this solution seems to
have
some experimental support in a paper for
nature communications
martin ringbauer simulated what would
happen if a photon
were sent back in time through a closed
time-like curve
and given an opportunity to negate its
own existence
by preventing the firing of the photon
gun that emitted the particle
in the first place he found that the
particle would always
only have a 50 percent chance of taking
on a property
that would cause the gun not to fire
making it entirely possible
that it never would do so indeed
since we know that quantum entanglement
seems to send
signals across time one might argue that
it
never could the event of the photon
being emitted in the first place
is the measurement that mandates that it
will never take on the property
necessary
to prevent itself from being emitted
once it arrives
in the past if this indeed is how time
travel would work
it would seem that causal loops and gin
would be common
skynet from the terminator saga really
could create itself by leaving a piece
of one of its terminators in the past
a time traveler could even find that
they're the cause of their own
time travel journey like cooper and
interstellar
and a time traveler really could be
their own father
mother child and killer like in the 2014
film predestination
based on the 1959 robert heinlein story
called all you zombies
but all this talk of time travel and
branching timelines
and alternate ways the universe could
have gone raises the question
of whether the universe has gone other
ways
or more specifically whether there are
other universes
that went a different way than ours
instead of creating an alternate
universe by traveling in the past
like say one where i'm never born are
there alternate universes
where i was already never born
are there alternate universes for every
way the universe could have gone
and if so could we ever travel to them
and what would be the philosophical
implications of such universes
to explore these issues i'd like you to
watch
i'd like you to watch an episode of star
trek the next generation
one called parallels season seven
episode 11.
as you watch ask yourself whether all
the versions of lieutenant wharf
wait what was the plural of wharf again
warbs
the plural of wharf is wharves how do
you know all of this
because i have a transcript of your
lecture from an alternate universe and
that's what it says
oh brilliant as you watch
ask yourself whether all the wharves at
the end of the episode
are the same person see you in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
you